yeah i also walk down the street with
her the you know over in Virginia and I
just said to her and I really mean this
I view her mm-hmm absolutely with no
sexuality I never have that's what a
girl likes to hear you yeah develop
woman you're asexual you're calling
nokia you're any Pinocchio your heart I
don't like what is this is this like you
know you have eyeballs in your hand like
if I just had tits you would think I was
hot if I had no today do you have a
magnificent ass that's all anyone area
much you know and then she goes out this
way yeah but that's that's like the best
type of proportions you don't want the
obvious that you don't want big tits and
no ass I like big boobs cuz I did mine
out
I had implants times I look at boobs and
I'm just like like it's a natural
response she does she does do that yeah
but you also love women I do I love
women yeah you've had many women
relations I've had some female lover
it's a lot of work a lot of work it is
emotionally or so emotionally sexually
I'm all the same do you so you're into
eating [ __ ] then yeah I have any I mean
I've been with Nick I've been not you
know I mean I'm an ovulation chip and
I'm always like let's have a threesome
and then I'm like no yeah we almost had
a foursome like not too long ago and it
wasn't good with that second couple or
with another couple and what I backed
out I was like I can't let's go planned
or how did that come about
I just got it's weird it was weird we
were just hanging out we're both in the
same a hotel and the only way you're
gonna feel okay about it is if you plan
it without him knowing and you surprise
him with it you have the control I want
to suck his dick with another girl but I
can't have the girl be someone we know
exactly in the city or there's an app
for that
render yes that's who should sponsor
this [ __ ] yes watching their Heywood's
because we were in I think's in a
different city one time and he was
sleeping I was bored and I was like but
I would only feel okay with it yeah I
loved it
yeah so if I orchestrated the whole
thing so that I had a girl that's a [ __ ]
me credit [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you're the
partner you [ __ ] guard oh yeah you're
never gonna find a girl that's gonna go
oh yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] every woman that
you've ever told me you fought they're
all beautiful women yeah if they have
specific you know me they see the thing
so other people will based on a photo
look I'm not I'm gonna interview her I'm
gonna be like hey show up one day the
reason is okay interview process hello
thank you for so much for coming what
about a tiger belly fan no because
that's you yeah they have these bands
because it's clean very clingy and they
can export your kazoo [ __ ]
orchestrated look I won't agree to this
unless I do all the planning without
your knowledge if I show up and it's so
[ __ ] you know ugly girl come on
exactly I've you know cuz I've been
going through a lot of like health
issues and I was feeling just extremely
unsexy and just yeah and I thought to
myself you know what that's something
that I that could spice it up even for
myself because he was getting pretty
lame too you know like that God like you
know we gotta turn this [ __ ] on a little
bit yeah it happens I should happen yeah
I don't think that it's something we
ought to not talk about it's honest and
it's real so yeah if if I if I propose
another [ __ ] and throw it were your way
you better accept you better accept if
you turn it down and oh [ __ ] it up for
ever
oh yeah I will never do it again no
trust she won't trust you threesome you
[ __ ] my watch I like why I like the
jealousy I feel it kind of gives me more
of a little
of fire I told you I told we've got flat
damn what happened yeah I wanna do it
I've ice I was like watching and I
thought I would be jealous and then I
was like into watching her on my hip I
was like okay no really yeah you ever
wants to go to the strip club with me
and he's like nope it's gonna graduate
into something else is gonna become some
we've done a couple couples lap dances
together but then the girl is always
like I have a boyfriend to me sexual
either okay okay okay we will try it
surprise me I know anyone thinking I
know my baby I know plenty of [ __ ] babe
trust me they're all girlfriends of mine
they're my throwaway friends then right
I just have hung out with here and there
but don't really have a real
relationship they're listening tonight
and then they get a phone call in a week
they're like oh no okay with it yeah
I know people like that yeah okay so let
me let's let's walk it through then okay
no I just want to walk it through I need
to walk it so give me a scenario so you
well how would you say that's what I
would do I would say hey I would
probably get a room at the line hotel or
something just just to tell you hey
let's spend the night here well let's go
so call me let's say let's say I'm down
the street yeah call me tell me how you
don't do it but anybody
bring-bring I would text you I wouldn't
call you that's what texted me that I
would surprise you and just say hey meet
me here let's have dinner here why we
let's go home I'll go to the Lions Hotel
know what happens and I say hey like I
got us a room you know to spice it up oh
I guess I can then go home so I go
upstairs right yeah yeah and then what
happens there's another email on the man
who's this and check oh hey hi you're
gonna ask questions I'm amber yeah I
have to ask questions who the [ __ ] is
this you know what come in you're
already making out with a guy yeah
that's a good way I can come in and
she's making out with her yeah wait this
isn't just for you this is also for me
you she's making out the girl and then
they look at you and they go like this
yeah and then and then what happen no
stop okay that's right yeah it's like
just watch TV what it's the new world
it's 2016 it's the new world and I have
to learn you know why it's maturity
being able to be open and sexually the
in not connecting emotion so is a
maturity that I don't have yet yeah I
don't think I ever want to live a life
so restricted to the point where I can't
tell my partner like hey these are my
desires I don't think I ever want a
prison or caged myself in that way and
that's the reason why Bobby is so
attracted to me because he has that same
you we talked about I would never cheat
on him I know he would never cheat on me
but should that should we ever cross
that bridge together we were like okay
you know what let's spice it up a little
bit I don't think that anyone would take
it personally or in a way other than
yeah like you know and I yeah I'm
interested report back to us okay I
think my mom was and my parents did that
but they just kept it on the down-low
back in the day yeah but the birth
situation her dad was how old was her
dad when you met your mom he was in his
- he made me I was his last lucky sperm
I was he was in his 60s my mom Oh is he
still alive
he died at 80 13 years ago Wow he was
old though 80 young live of - yeah so
you knew him for a long time that you
still got to know him for a long time
[Music]